luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to my show so this is sponsored um and powered by
iconplus so really quick news announcement for
you so icon loop and the seoul government have
announced the mass implementation of blockchain
based contactless online reservations for more
than seven thousand public services so always
really interesting news coming out from icon there
now as you know as always it is also i'm sponsored
by blockbuy so um you can actually on up to 8.6
interest on your on your uscc i use them and if
you follow the link there's a link somewhere maybe
scrolling at the bottom you can actually get up to
250 when you sign up now guys if you are watching
on youtube please don't forget to hit the like
button and hit subscribe so you never miss any
of these fantastic guests now joining me today i'm
really excited we don't know each other very well
so we're gonna get to know each other and it's
gonna be really fun so joining me today is the cio
and the founder of block tower capital it is
ari paul ari what's up how you doing doing well
how are you yeah i'm good i'm good we tried
to sort of get to know each other a little
bit before but we had some internet issues
so here we are so where where are you based
uh well today i'm in new york but um
our whole firm's going to be in miami
in a couple months and we've been with covid
we've been pretty spread out and decentralized
yeah i think this whole covert thing is just
insane because i feel like our industry is
the only industry which has really kind of
found its way you know we've been able to
shine we've been able to continue working we've
been able to you know just do what we do best
yeah the the one thing missing um and and i
say missing you know kind of half this issue
half facetiously are the uh just the conference
circuit which was such a big part of the 2017
experience um i had very mixed feelings about it
i'm an introvert i always found the conference
is exhausting even when they're fun and exciting
and and it's great energy and great people i still
like three hours and i'm i'm toast so um i i'm
kind of happy to be missing that on the other hand
it it there is a little the the
energy is amazing when you've got
2 000 people who are just religious fanatics
you know it's almost like a sporting event
yeah i know what you mean it's one of the things
that i really miss but it's something i keep
hearing from introverts like yourself say oh
well you know i haven't had to socialize you
know i don't have to do this i don't have to do
that but there is a conference in miami you said
you're going to go down to miami are you going
to be at the conference in june yeah i think it
seems like everyone's going to be there um i think
there's a bit of pent-up demand to meet in person
so i will be there uh yeah i'm sure it'll be
an exhausting whirlwind but also a lot of fun
yeah absolutely so i want to go back a bit and
understand a little bit about who you are um how
you got into this space so for those that don't
know who ahri is how would you describe yourself
um i'm an investing geek uh i i love thinking
about kind of economic history and history of
markets and cryptocurrency is such a fascinating
petri dish where it's like we actually get to
see the birth of a new asset class the growth
and mature maturation of markets um so i was
a trader at cisco international group at the
start of my career then i was an uh allocator
at the chicago endowment which is an 8 billion
endowment kind of long-term investing um so yeah
i came from kind of both ends of traditional
finance short-term trading long-term investing
and then in 2017 launched block tower and have
been all in as an understatement on crypto uh
24 7 markets you know i i do not have a
life outside of my job and this market
but you know dedicating your like you don't have
a life outside of it so dedicating your life to
the space something which is so new takes
so much conviction and so much passion so
how did you initially hear about bitcoin
because i saw an interview that you did and
you said when you first heard about it you
were like nah this is this is this isn't it
yeah it's i i like bringing this up every
once in a while it's just a reminder to be
to be humble and understanding of people who take
a while to come around to it so my the first uh
reference i can find in my email to coin was a
friend telling me to buy it or at least look at
it in 2011. and i didn't even remember like when
i launched block tower in 2017 i didn't remember
ever getting that email this was just like i
searched my inbox for the first reference and
my response to my friend um was cryptocurrency
will never have value because value comes from
either a long-term societal appreciation like gold
or fiat backed by guns so that was my categorical
dismissal the crypto will never be you know worth
anything in 2011. um and then it wasn't until 2014
that i bought bitcoin and i wasn't a convert
at that point i i dabbled and then i kind of
just gradually fell down the rabbit hole um spent
hundreds of hours learning each of the pieces you
know the basics of i i don't even want to say i
know the basics of cryptography because i don't
but i know enough to understand how cryptography
works in crypto and i know enough about blockchain
engineering to know that piece of the puzzle
um so i think for a lot of people in crypto
most people are initially dismissive
including i mean some of the core devs like um
gregory maxwell is one of the most uh prominent
bitcoin core developers and he famously in the
very beginning on one of the initial bitcoin kind
of discussion forums said this doesn't work it's
not byzantine fault tolerant so you know yeah
everyone i think adam back was the same who's
the founder of block stream and oh i didn't
know he was the same i didn't know adam back
yeah in the very beginning he was scout i mean
both of those guys have been in since i don't know
i think 2010 so this isn't meant to insult them at
all it's more it's the opposite it's just you know
even the people who built bitcoin um basically
everyone's initially skeptical and then you
have to kind of unwrap the pieces to understand
how they all work together and that this does
and part of the reason is that um there
is no magic bullet with bitcoin so it's
not like there's a single thing that solves
a critical problem in an obvious way so like
maxwell's initial objection was uh it actually
bitcoin doesn't solve the game theory problem it's
not actually byzantine fault tolerant it doesn't
perfectly coordinate and ensure finality and uh
security and all these things but it's practically
byzantine fault tolerance probabilistically fault
tolerant and so it requires a little bit of this
real world application to say like maybe this
will work in the wild and then we and then we see
proof you know we see it in the wild we see proof
of concept we see that proof of work has you know
worked for 11 years now or uh yeah eleven years
almost twelve twelve eleven basically twelve
so wait so twelve years so what was that right
twelve eleven because you've got yeah you've got
the the white paper and then the genesis blocking
us on but when was that aha moment because i
think i think you're totally right that everybody
straight away is just like gosh i'm really
skeptical of this um i mean just thinking back
the first time i'd heard of bitcoin was honestly
because um somebody i knew was buying drugs online
um and from silk road and that's just that's just
the harsh reality of it and that was back in 2013
so and it took years later until i even
invested or took an interest in it to be
honest so what was your aha moment i i really
didn't have a single moment um it's not unusual
generally new technology um it gets adopted by
pull and usually the pull is if it's something
disruptive it's often people who are not served
by the trade by whatever existed before and those
are often fringe communities or illegal or
marginalized communities um so not not at all
surprising that bitcoin's kind of first proof
concept would be would be drugs something that
traditional banking you know isn't gonna isn't
going to knowingly support um i say that banks
pay fines every year for knowingly supporting drug
trafficking so they do know that they supported
hey get out hsbc um so i don't yeah i don't think
it was a single moment it was um i was looking for
something like bitcoin because i thought basically
after the financial crisis since 2009 central
banks around the world are printing so much
fiat eventually this is going to be inflationary
what is like i i was actively i i really wanted
to financially bet on currency depreciation and i
so i was looking for something like bitcoin but
even when i saw bitcoin it didn't like really
click that this was the thing the thing for me
i think it was really just putting these pieces
together and answering the objections so when i
first looked at like there are a lot of legitimate
criticisms of bitcoin i i say legitimate in the
sense that they require a lot of work to overcome
so you have the game theory stuff like does proof
of work like if i looked at proof of work like
before bitcoin existed i would probably say this
won't work you know um and then on the you know
all these pieces you have to know enough about
the cryptography to understand why it's secure um
even the legal regulatory side like understanding
why it's not easy for like coin center does
great work on this and they argue that it's
unconstitutional for the us to just ban bitcoin
um and so having an understanding that like why
is that why is that because of a freedom of speech
standpoint in terms of the freedom to express
how what you want to buy like that um uh no i
don't i think they they may make that argument
for the first apologies to coin center because
i'm whatever i say is going to be a horrible uh
if not a misrepresentation at least certainly far
less articulate than than they were things um but
it no one of the arguments is um governments can't
well i shouldn't say governments the us government
can't arbitrarily uh dictate what we can buy and
sell so the idea of like one of the clauses in
the constitution is those rights not explicitly
delegated to the federal government or reserve
to the states so the federal government um it
basically needs a compelling reason to be able
to tell you what you can do and that reason is
very very broad basically the federal government
can regulate interstate commerce which gets used
as a catch-all but um they've argued that god i'm
really not going to do this justice um it's okay
i'm actually writing this down i'm
actually writing this round because
i really want to i'm literally i've got
this written down so unconstitutional
what was the company you said that spoke about it
oh well coin center they're a non-profit lobbying
group that is plays a really important role in our
industry um they they're kind of the non-profit
lobbying group they're definitely others but
they're they're the prominent ones and it's it's
run by jerry britto and um peter van walkenburg
uh and they they advocate for cryptocurrency
as sophisticated lawyers so they're constantly
writing legal arguments they they present those
to judges to legislators they act as lobbyists
uh to promote good legislation and oppose bad
stuff and they provide um legal fodder for lawyers
who are going to be defending any crypto startup
for example so when the sec is uh making broad
you know very broad statements about icos for
example coin center will issue very detailed legal
briefs in response and say you know or actually
a great example of this was um when the treasury
department in december was when they when they had
their proposed fincen rule uh by steven mnuchin
the treasury secretary coin center responded
something like two weeks later with a 70 page
brief uh kind of dissecting it and saying we think
this is illegal for like 19 different reasons it
was and it was it was actually amazing the list
of things that they claimed uh the the proposal
violated and from memory a few of them were like
the proposed rulemaking process was was illegally
short and they and it was um they didn't leave
proper time for comments and consideration and
it was and the fact that it was rushed violated
a few different ordinances and um and they felt
it violated uh what is it a fourth amendment
basically the the privacy penumbra because there
was no compelling reason for the information
they were demanding the coinbase turnover to
fincen um so just this long list of objections
that's really interesting i actually had no
idea that there was an objection that banning
obviously as a british person i had no idea
that banning bitcoin could potentially be
unconstitutional i need to look into that that's
that's really interesting but just on this topic
then i kind of wanted to wait a little bit until
we we delved into it but here we are i really
want to talk to you about energy because this is
something which has just been going on so much
from nfts to bitcoin every single day and this
is getting really political as well um every
single day um you know let's take the guardian
for example that's a really left-wing newspaper
in the uk and they're constantly talking about
how the energy consumption of bitcoin is just
insane so how how do you address that because i've
seen a lot of articles about it and i've seen a
lot of people talk about renewable energy and
actually how bitcoin is more to do with cleaner
energy but i honestly don't fully understand
so i would love for you to just explain this
sure um i nick carter has done some great work
nick uh is a fun manager in the space and and
uh an excellent writer he's written the closest
that we have to kind of the definitive rebuttal
on this um and if you just google search nick
carter and it's nick nic um nick carter bitcoin
energy a bunch of his essays will pop up um it's
a frankly it's a fairly simple set of arguments um
so okay uh electricity is hard to move from
place to place so recently in the us we had
people uh freezing in texas due to electricity
shortage even while we had plenty of electricity
on the east coast and us it's really hard to move
electricity a long distance and people don't know
i i was an electricity trader briefly at cisco
international group and i traded among other
things texas electricity and the first thing you
learn as an electricity trader is the u.s and the
world have very very separate electricity markets
and electricity doesn't really flow between them
only there's basically like these tiny connections
between texas is known as ercot that's the name of
the power grid uh the northeast has something
called pjm which is an acronym for pennsylvania
new jersey and maryland and those are distinct
energy grids and very very little electricity
can move across them um that's not by the way
necessarily always going to be true you can build
uh kind of the right kinds of power lines to move
a lot of power but the world basically hasn't the
us certainly hasn't so um so okay part of the
reason this is a complex topic is just there's
it's not rocket science but there's a lot of this
kind of like specific info that people aren't
familiar with you know um okay so hard to move
power place to place almost all other electricity
demand is local in the sense that you typically
need your power plant and your generator uh right
near an industrial center you'd be because it's
hard to move electricity long distance where does
electricity get gets you get used it gets used
by factories and by urban centers so bitcoin's
the exception bitcoin you really you can have a
giant bitcoin mining farm with three employees
so you can build that anywhere in the world
and so what happens is the cheapest electricity
tends to be in very remote places and it tends
to be renewable so things like uh geothermal
in iceland and scandinavia hydroelectric power in
the pacific northwest as well as northwest china
um renewables and like wind farms solar farms
uh they're cheapest to build where there's no
people where land is very very cheap so
what what's been happening is every year
more and more of bitcoin's mining power comes
from renewables and it incentivizes research
and renewables because it's an arms race it's
a hyper competitive competition among people
to find the cheapest source of power anywhere in
the world and it happens that the innovation is
really happening in the on the renewable side
coal isn't really getting any cheaper and it's
happening in far-flung remote areas so that's
the renewable bit coming in i'm missing that
bit where's the renewable bit coming in so
the distinction is that with fossil fuels uh
they kind of are where they are so the coal
deposits will be wherever they are um the uh
well so it's two things one it's location a lot
of the renewables are by far cheapest in very
remote places where they're not attractive to
traditional industry so solar and wind are just
a great example where like solar panels take
up a huge amount of physical space you're not
going to build a giant solar farm outside of new
york city because the land's too expensive right
so the place basically this is the use case where
renewables are naturally the most competitive that
makes bitcoin one of the first kind of general
adopters of renewable energy at giant scale
and and you get economies of scale you get
efficiency and so when you have a lot of
people around the world investing hundreds of
millions of dollars in trying to build the most
competitive bitcoin mining farm they can that's a
lot of money getting put into renewables research
and even just economies of scale so for example
like photo photovoltaic cells solar panels um
they're much cheaper the more you make of them and
so the problem historically has been this is part
of the reason why governments will you know try to
subsidize renewable energy uh one of the economic
reasons is okay if you build one solar panel
it's crazy expensive and it's super uncompetitive
but if you build a million of them it's actually
only a little bit more expensive than oil and
so if the government subsidizes to get to a
certain scale then it actually doesn't need
to be that big of a subsidy because solar panels
aren't that uncompetitive at scale and in a few
years solar panels are actually going to be
cheaper than oil in many parts of the world
um and when i say a few years i don't i'm
not in the weeds on exactly how long but
like a lot of energy experts are projecting
five to ten years until solar panels generally
are just cheaper as a source of energy
than oil so this is a temporary problem
in 10 years bitcoin is almost certainly going to
be mostly renewable energy and i actually think
it's a positive environmentally because it pushes
for innovation in renewables in a way that is then
going to cause even industrial centers to use
more renewable energy okay so firstly thank you
for that that was actually really helpful that
actually was like really really super helpful
but given that okay i've got it now but why is
this so difficult for people to jump on board with
do you think that it's actually not that difficult
for them to understand it's more just they don't
like it it doesn't fit the narrative um bitcoin
is too disruptive so let's just find some fud
and yeah i think it's largely look for for the
audience of those articles i don't fault a reader
because um but nothing i said was that complicated
but it was a little bit of quirky knowledge that
most people don't have like most people don't
know how electrical grids work right you know
like why would you why would you know that so
um for the readers of the articles i think they
they're just getting fooled by bad journalism
the journalists um have a very clear it's just
such a simple easy headline in narrative right
it's it's something that sells papers it's a
it it feels moralistic it makes the journalist
feel good it makes the reader feel good
right you get to feel smug and superior and if
people are making money on this thing um i mean
bitcoin is is such an attractive populist whipping
boy i think we are going to see more pushback um
in that look no one um who's a more hateable
group than the crypto rich right you've got
a bunch of uh frankly largely at least in
the western hemisphere largely white dudes
the whole you know bitcoin bro idea um there's
some truth to that in the sense that you know
the the crypto community in the western hemisphere
is it it combines all of the negative demographics
of its pieces so like the trading industry is male
dominated and white dominated and computer science
is male and white and cryptography is male
and white uh and so it's not a surprise
that cryptocurrency which is kind of the
intersection of those things would you know
be more that so you've got um young people who
are getting stupidly rich without much effort
and you know crypto people they like to talk
about oh it's so hard to huddle don't tell me
that it's like easy to you know survive these
massive swings and we've earned our 100 x's
it's like to me that's so insulting to an
entrepreneur who worked three jobs to like buy
a house you know i mean like i'm not saying it's
easy to huddle through an eighty percent dip but
normally in life through it you could sleep
through it but you couldn't sleep through
building a company basically right people don't
usually like in in life people don't usually make
millions of dollars tens of millions of dollars
by not clicking a button right it usually a lot
more work goes into making 10 million dollars
so you know you've got young people who are
um like a a a an easy demographic to
attack who got rich without trying
it's just a very attractive kind of populist
target right it feels like undeserved wealth
and so tacking on any other moralistic things
tacking on the environmental stuff tacking on
um i think fairly soon we'll start seeing wealth
inequality arguments you know we'll start hearing
uh from the progressive side like you know slap
a one-time wealth tax on bitcoiners the same way
it's like tax billionaires well at least most well
not i don't know about most but you know plenty
of the billionaires people are talking about
swapping a wealth tax on actually built companies
of tremendous value to the world you know and
and you take someone like a bezos and i'm not
personally a big fan of facebook or zuckerberg
but like zuckerberg's a billionaire because he
built something that people like using right and
he built it over you know more than a decade and
and built it out competed everyone and so say
what you will he at least worked for it you know
um and gave the world something the world wanted
whether the world should have wanted it or not
um so yeah i i think we should be we should
expect more attacks and that's just life i
hate that narrative so much i hate the narrative
of like hate billionaires tax billionaires more
because it's just like then stop using
their products if you hate them so much
like just just give it up um i hate it it
really disincentivizes people to want to
actually make something of themselves but just
that narrative there as well is really interesting
because that it's you know it's for you know
the white men's rich trading club or whatever
because there's a huge um niche within
cryptocurrency which is actually not
even a niche to be honest um which is actually
it's helped so many people from really terrible
backgrounds turn their entire lives around um
whether it be in trading just buying bitcoin or
whatever it is i mean there's even isaiah jackson
who um has the book um i think it's um was it
bitcoin bit oh god what is that black bitcoin
what's it called i can't remember yeah i'm
blanking on the name uh but i i know you're
pointing on black america maybe it's bitcoin and
black america i think that's the name yeah and he
and he talks about um how black people should get
reparations in bitcoin and that is just completely
contradictory to the narrative that i guess they
want you to believe um so i mean even even for
me i'm in my 20s and i'm so grateful for bitcoin
because i've been able to turn a lot of things
around and you know i don't have to now think
oh gosh inflation how on earth did i now you know
invest in the stock market like i now need to you
know run a job run this run that and also learn
how to trade and invest and all that but you know
my generation has bitcoin um something that
you know didn't have before yeah it is a
generational wealth transfer um and agree that it
is democratizing um in many ways and it creates
huge amounts of entrepreneurial opportunity
for people who are i mean there's so many
uh young people with no resume who've been able
to create successful companies in the industry
right just because it's it's so new that there
can't have a pedigree so definitely agree with
that and i'm i'm also a huge believer in the
humanitarian benefits i just think it's not
it's not quite the progressive liberal kind of
uh agenda it's it's a much more um libertarian
one in the sense that i love it like yeah so part
of what first drew me to bitcoin was the idea that
people can flee a totalitarian state with their
wealth now so like i had relatives some who
fled nazi germany some who didn't and to to
anyone in a totalitarian state whether it's
nazi germany kimmer rouge um frankly china today
you kind of have a choice you can usually escape
a totalitarian regime with the shirt on your back
like it's usually on in most of these examples
there was kind of at least a window before
the border closed when you could have fled
but you would have been fleeing into poverty
right if you were a middle class cambodian or
jew or a hong kong resident if your choice
is go to european refugee camp for years
abandon your livelihood your family you know
basically thrust your family into extreme poverty
or take your you know roll the dice that this
totalitarian regime will hopefully revert to
you know the country that you've lived in and
love and and that you you know you hopefully can
trust your neighbors um a lot of people stay
whereas if you could leave and being able to
flee the country just you know with a password in
your head you could take your wealth with you um
i think it it is an incredible weapon against
totalitarianism it's going to allow people in
general to flee totalitarian states with their
wealth faster more aggressively that undercuts the
totalitarian state itself because it pulls wealth
out of the country um so it it it's yeah i'm
a huge believer in cryptocurrency from the human
rights perspective but it's not a wealth equalizer
it's not like a lower middle-class person in
america is automatically going to close the gap
with billionaires because of bitcoin so it's it's
humanitarian in helping the worst off in the world
the people who truly truly are oppressed not
the people who are just unhappy with the wealth
and equality yeah and i think that's such an
interesting point you know in terms of fleeing
um fleeing these regimes because just back
to nazi germany jews were swallowing gold
when they had that time when they had that gap
when you know people knew something was i think
after like crystal nuts or whatever it was
like after that people had that gap and they
knew get your papers and go they were swallowing
gold i can't remember whether it's in the film i
can't remember i was watching shin as list
but i don't know if the scene is in that or
not i can't remember or whether it's a museum
but i just remember seeing a picture of people
swallowing gold and just thinking wow like that's
insane like the portability of bitcoin you know
yeah yeah and uh gold precious uh precious
jewels um i have a friend whose family fled
from cambodia with a piece of jade and that piece
of jade was the start of their life in canada
what's jade forgive me i don't know what jade
is oh it's uh it's a stone that is very precious
particularly in asian cultures um i i think it's
it's mostly mined in asia but it's just also very
culturally significant um i i feel bad saying
asia i'm just very ignorant of i know it's uh
part of chinese culture i don't know if it's
other part of other asian countries so i'm
ignorant but the moral of the story was this
rock was the key to them escaping with wealth
um but yeah i mean obviously cryptocurrency
is infinitely better you're not having quarter
guards check your stool if you're right swallowing
gold is certainly not ideal no it's not ideal but
you know it was done but okay so you're obviously
really into bitcoin your perception changed you've
dedicated your um your now career to all of this
um but i know that you're not a bitcoin maximalist
um so i do want to talk about that because that's
something that i'm kind of um navigating actually
at the moment and it's all really interesting
what's happening particularly with defy ethereum
okay so i'm not going to ask you what are your
thoughts because that's just a terrible question
yeah but i wanna kind of okay tell me where where
do you draw that line between a [ __ ] coin and
bitcoin that's my question so i think to to me uh
it's actually very frustrating because the trying
to debate the no coiners like nouriel roubini
or peter schiff is frustrating because they
make such simply wrong statements and so everyone
in crypto gets frustrated like roubini will say
you know it's tulips it's a bubble and then it's
like well you've been saying that for seven years
and the tulip bubble lasted eight months and
tulips weren't programmable censorship resistant
depreciation resistant provably scarce like it's
a terrible analogy and you're just wrong and you
you keep being wrong um and then say you know same
with like roubini five years ago was saying well
uh there's no institutional adoption well yeah
it was too early and now we see it right so so
all those arguments are just um they're obviously
either unfair and that it's just too early you
know someone's saying the first year bitcoin was
created this isn't accepted by merchants worldwide
therefore it's a failure it's like it's been
around for a year like this is like female in 1974
right so i find the bitcoin maximalist arguments
identical and it's weird in that literally
the arguments are almost word for word the same
as norio roubini's the anti-bitcoin arguments are
identical to the anti-shit coin arguments to
the word if you replace bitcoin with ethereum
let's say so the maximalist arguments when i got
in this industry really five years ago were uh
anything that you want to do in crypto you can do
on bitcoin yeah that was a big one and my answer
and at the time there wasn't that much being done
in crypto right dfi didn't exist yet nfts didn't
exist yet um you really didn't have much happening
like there wasn't you couldn't use crypto for much
other than simple story value and payments so
it wasn't obviously wrong but my i i said i bet
you're going to be wrong maybe eventually you're
right maybe in five 10 years bitcoin will evolve
to be able to offer anything but there's gonna be
a huge amount of time where bitcoin is optimizing
for stability and security meaning it's gonna it's
to the extent it evolves at all it's gonna evolve
very slowly and eventually we may get everything
we want via layer twos but certainly in 2016 2017
there was nothing like that on the horizon
and now we've seen the the maximum argument
was wrong in that there's a lot of stuff you can
you that people value and can't do on bitcoin so
today um it's still the same arguments the
maximalist will still say well you could in theory
do d5 and bitcoin you could in theory do nfts
on bitcoin and it's like well sure but you can't
and eventually maybe you will be able to and
great like that's the nature it's almost like
saying like amazon has no value because in theory
jpmorgan chase could evolve to do the same thing
as them well great like let's let's talk in 10
years like okay if you know but amazon clearly
has value today so there's incredibly uh there's
incredible adoption and usage of d5 and nfts today
there's more than 100 000 owners of topshop for
example those are largely people who've never
touched any other cryptocurrency and bought uh
mba collectibles on the flow blockchain those
don't exist on bitcoin maybe someday they will
but in the interim people are getting value from
flow they're getting value from uh mba top shots
similarly with defy eventually maybe this will
be on bitcoin but for the time being people are
getting value from defy on ethereum so we see the
product market fit we see the adoption we see the
usage and we see that we can get stuff people want
uh with provable product market fit on platforms
other than bitcoin so the maximalists are just
wrong they've been wrong for five years um
when they mock icos they've been wrong like
you know the no coiners when bitcoin dips from
60k to 50k they're like see we were right it's a
bubble crash right and it's like well you've been
saying that since bitcoin was 100 so no you're not
right because it dipped so the the maximalists say
the same thing when an ico fails it's like oh one
ico failed icos in general have made investors
tons of money they've outperformed bitcoin
um an investor you know people who've been calling
ethereum scam since 2014 they're like see i was
right because bitcoins ethereum's underperformed
bitcoin for the last six months it's like
no you weren't right if you put one bitcoin
into the ethereum ico um i believe it would now
be worth 3.6 million dollars you would have made
more than 40x your bitcoin so um there there's a
because i'm quite i'm quite direct with things so
this is just the way my mind works but whatever
so of course you've got the likes of adam
back who you know they know what they're
talking about they're fantastic but i'm
outside of those um let's call them pioneers
outside of these kind of people you have
people just in the community and do you find
that there's a lot of bitcoin maximalism
potentially comes from the fact that they maybe
don't understand defy or don't haven't done enough
research and it's kind of easier just to sort of
um you know push something aside and disregard
it and just find let's say home in a community
and find protection in a community rather
than being brave enough to potentially
um you know think actually hang on people can you
know take out loans and mortgages in countries
that don't have any financial infrastructure what
do you think i i think it really varies by person
uh some of some there are some maximalists who are
very informed and educated about everything else
and for some of them um it comes from basically
there are a lot of [ __ ] coins there are true
[ __ ] coins that are outright scams that are
rug you know rug pull is it some of them are
true scams there's a lot of those right people
who are intentionally scamming by icos or new
coin launches there's a lot of that and then some
of them are accidental scams where you know you've
got a couple kids they might be well intentioned
they don't know what they don't know and so like
uh some of the people who criticize ethereum
will say okay maybe it's not a deliberate scam
but they think it's an accidental scam because
they think it's um not secure enough so a common
criticism was um ethereum intends to migrate to
proof of stake and proof of stake doesn't work
and the problem with the argument the proof of
stake doesn't work is it's the exact same logic
of the people who said proof of work doesn't work
which is on paper it has vulnerabilities there's
no question that proof of stake is of questionable
security we don't know that it's secure there's
known vulnerabilities but all of that was true
of proof of work and the only reason that we
trust proof of work is not because like that the
math is perfect it's because it works in practice
so um those same people uh including people like
greg maxwell who were skeptical of proof of work
it's a it's the same psychology that makes
it's basically a conservative investment
investing mindset it's you know someone comes
up with something innovative and new and cool
and you see that it's not perfect there are
holes in it legitimate legitimate vulnerabilities
and so one type of person says this is innovation
right and and they're not going to get it perfect
on the first try it's going to be you know
a work in progress and other people say
this thing isn't perfect and it's trying to take
on my beloved bitcoin it's it's trash it's garbage
it's you know it's fundamentally flawed so you
know if you view this as a work in progress um
it's much easier to be kind of tolerant
of the experimentation and the foibles and
i view this industry much more through the vc
lens which is you don't expect anything to be
right on the first try you expect teams to pivot
you expect the engineering to evolve over time
um so that's that's a big part of it
and then i think another part is um
some people so the same way that a roubini a
no coiner will point at the long tail of scam
cryptocurrencies and say all cryptocurrencies
are bad look at all these ico scams bitcoin is
a scam too it's tainted by association a lot of
the maximalists apply the exact same thinking
right they just exclude bitcoin so they say ari
i don't care if there's one or two or five icos
that are real that are not scams that are
innovative that are interesting technology
and they may have a real use case come on
ari like 99.9 percent of this stuff is crap
and my answer to that would be so do you include
bitcoin as part of that crap no you carve out
bitcoin you say it you you say just because 99.9
percent of cryptocurrencies are crap doesn't mean
bitcoin's crap and i just go one step further and
i say just because 99.9 of cryptocurrencies crap
doesn't mean bitcoin in these 10 others are crap
so it's partly just where do you draw the line
and and your comment about like a little bit of
lack of knowledge or intellectual laziness i think
does play a role there it's are you willing to
separate the wheat from the chaff and bitcoiners
it's just they stop at bitcoin yeah i mean it's
a bit of a it's a bit of a head spin because i
i remember i put out a comment sort of saying matt
you know because there's a lot of tribalism i put
out a comment saying imagine not liking someone
you know personally really having a dislike to
them because they prefer a different coin to
you and i always found i've never forgotten the
response i got to that which was people calling
the likes of vitalik and many other people
actual scammers um comparing them to charles
ponzi um bernie madoff and all these things
and i couldn't believe i couldn't believe
the comparison and i think that for me was
like the first time i really kind of like
swallowed the tribalism pill and was like
i felt that yeah i will say a lot of the tribalism
is for show it's it's marketing and signaling
and um because a lot of the bitcoin core
developers and self-proclaimed maximalists
actually have exposure to other coins many have
actually launched other coins so a huge percentage
of all cryptocurrencies have actually been
launched by bitcoin core developers um now many of
those people end up being kind of excommunicated
later so uh whether it's the bitcoin hard forks
whether it's um wait but i think i don't
remember charles hoskinson was a bitcoin
core dev a lot of the founders of other coins
uh decred was founded by charles was eighth so
um i'm not sure we our viewers can
check but but uh a lot of founders of um
let's see which other ones um i don't know if
ricardo is a bitcoin core dev but but a lot of the
monero community was definitely bitcoin miners and
early adopters d-cred was founded by bitcoin core
devs uh a lot of them were and um mimbo wimble
uh oh sorry grin was founded by a current bitcoin
core developer um which is a mimblewimble coin
implementation sorry not number wimblecoin is its
own thing by another bitcoin og trace meyer who
was showing it um but or and then you have like
i i think it's in x token uh a bunch of the block
stream employees launched in the erc20 equity coin
and uh there's a great example where like these
are bitcoin maximalists who call ethereum a scam
and they launched a token on ethereum and they
did that because it was the best way to fundraise
and it was the best way to issue an equity
token for their exchange um so a lot of it is
public signaling to build brand and a lot of these
maximalists that monetize their brand by selling
um trading seminars and and carnivory dinners and
their books and at the same time they're investing
uh like uh i believe with safadeen publicly said
um uh steven's the author of what the bitcoin
standard and a very public and aggressive bitcoin
maximalist he invested in the ethereum pre-sale
and he said publicly lost he lost his keys um
now he he says now to be fair anyone can change
their mind the fact that he invested in the ico
doesn't mean he's not allowed to then become a
maximalist and he says he then realized it
was a scam but my point is just um most of
the maximalists have exposure to other coins
a lot of them are are trying to virtue signal
yeah this is a really interesting point i had a
conversation with um the ceo of uh a company in
this in the crypto space the other day and he
said that to me he said to me leia they're all
investing in other coins and i was like i'm i i
have um i'm very i'm very honest person so what
you see is what you get with me i'm very straight
up so to me the idea that you know you have people
talking about bitcoin only and then they are in
using times like [ __ ] coins and they're actually
investing in other things i really took me back
i couldn't believe it um so i'm really fascinated
by that i think that's really interesting um
but let's talk about nfts because nfts are
really hot right now and there's two things
going on here from my um from my perspective
so we've got this supposed bubble right whereby
if something is just inherently an nft then you
know eventually it will be you know invest now
because it's the next big thing it's the uber
it's whatever it is it's facebook but then also
so there's that which i'm not really interested in
but then there's also just the idea of um giving
something a digital identity and verifying it and
for me that is really powerful for example um
you know rolex watches louis vuitton handbags
being able to literally track where it came
from so my brother's really into rolex watches
and he's telling me that if you buy it through
this country that country then it's actually
um less valuable if you buy it for example he
was he was telling me oh because this watch came
through dubai it's actually less valuable than
the same rolex watch which came through europe and
stuff like that so for that reason i'm like cool
i get it but i i'm not i'm not understanding this
this bubble over here which is supposedly you know
buy now and then you know sell it off later like
crypto kitties or you know swords and this and
that that you get in games yeah um nfts were such
a no-brainer to me as a obvious early theme for
crypto one of the first use cases to go mainstream
um for like 18 different reasons uh you know
the world is being digital people living more
and more of their lives you know people use crypto
um crypto punks to signal on social media it's the
modern version of having a picasso on your wall
someone has a half million dollar crypto punk as
their twitter avatar and now you know especially
with kovid we're all spending all our time online
we can't really show off our homes to friends
and so we're showing off our online identities
and increasingly that's going to become
metaverse identities whether it's a world
of warcraft type game you know people spend so
much money on skins for example and it's largely
gen z and young millennials who will spend you
know if they're spending 30 hours a week with
their friends in a game the idea of decorating
their character with and spending the same amount
of money that you would spend on a rolex or a
gucci handbag makes total sense because that's
your that's where your you get to socially peacock
that's where you get to impress your friends and
show off your taste your style um and then as
you noted there's the providence side which is um
like a concern i personally have is if i i haven't
bought uh almost any like high-end collectibles
and part of the reason is i'm concerned that
we're passing this point where forgeries are
indistinguishable from the real so every year
christie's and sotheby's gets tricked into selling
ten tens of millions of dollars of forged art
forged wine and that's with their experts closely
examining it that you know they do every test
that they do spectrographic tests they do you know
that's under a microscope they're getting fooled
by forgeries so people tell me um this is a common
like debate i say on twitter there are now
rolex forgeries and gucci handbag forgeries
and picasso forgeries that you can't distinguish
from the real thing and everyone's like no no i
can tell the difference no you can't you could
tell the difference 20 years ago you can tell
the difference from a cheap knockoff there are now
rolexes being made and they're not super cheap to
make so if it's a knockoff of a 20 000 rolex they
cost 2 000 to make because they're made with real
materials they're made with like it's an it's a
solid gold rolex they just came out of a different
warehouse basically exactly exactly they um i
saw this youtube clip of someone comparing a real
paddock uh to a knockoff including a turbine
tourbillon which i'm probably mispronouncing
which is like a really expensive handmade um
thing that slightly increases the precision of
the time and it was a watch enthusiast looking
at both with like a jeweler's loop and he's like
i can just barely tell the difference and it's
and both were handcrafted both were handmade
and some of the parts probably came out of
the exact same factories so you know so the
problem is if if i can't tell that you know if
i'm an enthusiast and i really like let's say
paddock watches and i want to spend forty thousand
dollars on one but i know that i can't tell the
difference between that and a 3 000 knock off and
i know that no one looking at it will be either
to either and i can't even tell the difference
then how do i justify spending the 40k so nfts
um now i don't think humans are going to suddenly
stop valuing authenticity right we're still going
to value authenticity we're still going to want to
have the original the real brand item so the only
way to solve for that is with a cryptographic
signature to prove authenticity yeah i mean
i'm just excited okay so i also agree with you
when you say everything is going online it's an
argument that i always make right whether it be um
dating socializing eating um the way we order food
everything is online so it only makes sense that
you know we will move everything online just okay
actually it's how someone explained it to me and
i thought it was really cool so instagram and
facebook is basically like kind of like you were
saying it's how you peacock online it's how you
show yourself off um and if you try to explain
that let's say to your grandparents grandparents
that you would have this um version of yourself on
the online that gives you value supposedly they'd
be like but what about just the value in real
life you know why do you need an online version of
yourself and i think that's where for me i haven't
taken that step in terms of nfts because i can't
think why would i need an online art room you know
i'm just sort of thinking why would i need that
but for some reason i feel the need to have an
online photo gallery of myself on instagram yeah i
think um a little bit of this is uh it's early in
that we don't really have the metaverses yet so we
have games and and we do have stuff like sim life
um but the reality is most people are not spending
that much time in these non-game metaverses
that's going to change um the technology's
getting better in a post-covered world uh you know
like there was a virtual burning man last year
there was a vr burning man there was a vr you know
crypto conferences and they're very basic today
but that's where the world's headed so um yeah
i do think nfts are a bubble in the sense that
uh if you take the average nft today it's
probably worth less than a year with that said
i so i agree with that and i wouldn't passively
buy a basket of nfts today but um it's gonna grow
horizontally 100x in the next three years 100x
and that's such a clear bet because uh well it's
hard to bet on um it's hard to bet on horizontal
growth in an industry but all of the ip owners
are racing to do deals so nba topshot has been
so successful for the mba it's such a proof of a
successful proof of concept that all the other
leagues all the top musicians everyone says
holy crap these guys just minted 200 million
dollars out of nowhere selling collectibles
um you know djs like blau blah did you know blau's
been um in the in the crypto industry for like
five years uh the guy is a world-class dj but also
has really put in his time in crypto he's been
a passionate early adopter for i don't know when
he when he first got in but um he was actually
in our offices pitching a startup in 2018. um
and uh he ended up calling off the startup at
least on the fundraising side because he ended
up not loving the business model um and i have
nothing but respect for him by the way uh so he
did 11 million dollars of sales in one day selling
musical nfts um their their musical with visuals
um he has a graphic designer that he works with
and every dj in the world sees that i mean
that's real money for even the highest end
performers you know a steve aoki a a taylor
swift a beyonce the idea that you can do 11
million dollars of sales in a day is meaningful
numbers for every artist and musician in the world
so um everyone's coming all the musicians
celebrities uh sports teams athletes everyone is
coming and wants to get a piece of the demand that
they see is there i think that's what's so insane
about 2021 and this whole bull market in general
is that it's just so different to 2017 this
this is mainstream like i got in just at the end
of 2017 and there was this constant i i used to
do hard news basically hard crypto news and there
was this constant conversation about mass adoption
you know like on twitter when people are
basically like making fun of something and
they do like the capital letters and the lower
letters that's i don't that makes sense that's
how i feel about mass adoption when i hear the
word mass adoption i just hear like mass adoption
like it's just this really cringy term but like it
is now like it's happening now which is so insane
um to see it happening i mean even soldier boy
just it's just you know it's just more than 2017
so i think it's really insane um but i want to
move on a little bit and i want to talk um a bit
about entrepreneurship um because block tower and
so on so you guys actually launched in 2007 was
it 2017 in the middle of the bull market so by
the time you were sort of fully up and running
we were in a bear market so firstly that's insane
that blew my mind when i when i learned about that
so major congrats and how did how did you how
did you do that like how did you how did you
as such a new company survive just basically
plunging into the bear market because i don't
think anybody expected a you know 20k down to
three i don't think anyone kind of expected that
yeah um frankly it was brutal as an entrepreneur
um uh brutal and we were fortunate in that if we
hadn't launched when we did we launched in uh
mid-august 2017 like anyone who launched in say
december with a long bias crypto strategy almost
impossible to survive because really in finance
um you really can't survive uh well so first a
sentence on how hedge funds work uh for for your
audience um typically hedge funds try to get by on
their management fee so a common structure will be
something like two and twenty meaning they charge
two percent of a fee uh you charge two percent a
year on your asset base so if you're running a
billion dollar fund that'd be 20 million a year
and you charge carry on performance and in
traditional finance typically hedge funds
uh pay their operating expenses with the
management fee and hope to get rich on kerry
um in crypto it's the scale it's very hard to get
to the scale where the management fee covers your
expenses so um i mean a newly launched crypto fund
generally is not going to raise a billion dollars
um the only crypto funds that have gone to a
billion dollars to my knowledge have gotten there
largely organically meaning they've they've maybe
they raised 100 million and then crypto 10x and so
now they're a billion dollars so almost everyone
basically loses money on the management fee
we did through most of our history and um you
really have to think of yourself more as like
a growth startup and so do you have the capital to
finance losses for years to grow to get to a scale
that you're a profitable enterprise so that was
how we thought of ourselves from the beginning
um literally when we launched i told my co-founder
uh i'm probably not going to time it perfectly but
there is going to be an 80 crash probably in
the next year or two and our job is to survive
that bear market and if we survive it we'll
be an industry leader because almost no one's
going to survive it and i i'm a big believer that
franchises in finance as well as in traditional in
in any industry get built in bear markets that's
when you step when when the going is good there's
just a lot of competition there's a lot of faces
in the crowd there's a lot of people doing well
it's when the tide comes out you see who's
swimming without clothes and most people give
up or they they don't have a choice they lose
too much money or their investors abandon them
so if you're able to survive that bear market
you're in a really good position whether you're
amazon coming out of the tech crash whether you're
uh you know a finance company um so for us i think
it was really we expected there to be a protracted
bear market and psychologically prepared for it
financially prepared for it it's not to say we
traded it perfectly we didn't it's not like i
timed the market you know anywhere near perfectly
at all but just being psychologically ready um
you know like my whole team i told them once a
week guys be mentally ready there's going to be
an 80 crash to your bear market like we're
in it for the long haul and if you're not
like you need to be mentally prepared for this
um and then one piece of it is frankly just um
willing to make the bet to keep going so
um for uh hedge funds if you're under water
meaning if you lose money you don't get to
collect carry until your investors are back above
the high water mark and the idea is that you
don't get to collect carry twice on the same move
so for example if a hedge fund goes up 100 the
year ends they get to collect carry if it then
falls a hundred percent sorry sorry falls fifty
percent and then goes up 100 again you shouldn't
get to collect terry a second time on that same
move right it wouldn't be fair to your investors
so what happens in a bear market is hedge funds
are wildly underwater they might be 30 50 70
underwater which means you're not really making
any money until you first earn a 200 or 300 or 400
return most hedge funds just shut down they're
like man we're not making any money for years
we have to earn a 300 return just before we get
paid a dollar why would we stay open so uh that
happens to almost every hedge fund in crypto if
you're running any kind of long bias strategy
you're almost certainly going to lose money in a
bear market and like my goal is always to lose a
lot less than crypto but um i'm actually not even
trying to make money from the decline um i think
it's too hard you can run an absolute return or a
market neutral strategy or an arbitrage strategy
that's great but if you're trying to capture the
beta if you're trying to capture the 10x upside
very very hard to be net short through the bear
market so my goal is um try to outperform when
crypto's going up and then try to lose a lot less
when crypto's going down and if you do both those
things then you end up with a very very good
return over a full cycle but my point though
is you're still losing money in the bear market
you still need to have the fortitude the grit
the belief that there's going to be another bull
run and you're willing to invest just you know
to see that through yeah i think the thing which
really just stuck out there was the idea of just
preparing not just yourself but everyone around
you the entire team is saying guys you know this
isn't gonna this is gonna be difficult the bear
market is coming when you know that i think it's
all about reality isn't it just sort of having
that reality check and knowing things don't
always go up so just hold on tight and we're in it
for the long run but yeah but for people who okay
so i get this question a lot um and so for people
who um aren't necessarily technical or they don't
or they don't have an investor background like
you have an investing background like you have
how how can they get involved like how can they
see okay i like this space politically i'm aligned
um what can i do to get involved as an
entrepreneur what tips would you give them
yeah i think um the starting point is is really
what work you want to be doing if you're an
artist getting involved in you know creating
nft art is a great idea if you're an accountant
um applying your skill set if you're
a lawyer applying basically all of the
skill sets that exist in the world are useful
in crypto so marketing pr hr recruiting um
you know you're an example of this where you're
you're running a business that is not inherently
a crypto business but you're applying it to crypto
right um so it happened to be that my skill set
was trading and investing you know i applied that
to crypto but um so i think the starting point is
what is your skill set and if you're very young
like let's say you're just coming out of college
what what do you want to be doing with your
life what kind what's what's the work you want
to be doing so like and i think this is a useful
exercise for anyone looking at any job which is
there's kind of two decisions which is what
industry do you want to be in and then what
role do you want to have so an accountant working
for uh a university uh not you know a non-profit
an accountant working for general electric you're
still doing accounting work the industry matters
a lot but your day-to-day it matters more what is
your role right are you a true like if i'm trading
bitcoin or i'm trading that gas i'm still a trader
and my day-to-day is not that different if i don't
like trading i shouldn't be a trader it doesn't
matter what industry i'm in same with um if you
don't you know don't be a crypto account if you
don't like accounting don't be a crypto lawyer if
you don't like if you don't want to be a lawyer
so i think it starts with um okay you know what
industry you want to be in but now what is your
career path and if you couldn't imagine doing it
if it wasn't crypto it's probably not going to
be a good fit like don't become an accountant
just to become a crypto account right if you
don't like accounting it's not gonna last um
but within that it's it's every skill set is
necessary you know people are building uh like
i'm thinking of um uh bobby who runs i think it's
called proof of talent which is a recruiting firm
and it's a recruiting firm it's a recruiting
that's cool yeah i'm pretty sure i'm getting
the name right proof of talent uh i'm blanking
on his last name but it's very well respected
well regarded they've placed a ton of people at
crypto funds crypto firms um uh i i don't have any
connection i'm not trying to show them or anything
but um i i've i i've only heard good things about
them and i've referred a couple people um to them
just to be helpful uh it's just an example where
a guy said you know i i'm a recruiter i want to
build a recruiting firm here's a nascent industry
which is going to make it right if you're trying
to build a recruiting firm in the oil and gas
industry you're competing against incumbents who
know everyone who've been doing it forever who
have the rolodexes very hard to start a company
so but blue ocean right bobby was able to build a
big profitable meaningful valuable recruiting
firm because it's a new industry in crypto
yeah i think that's also something which i can
totally relate to because you know coming into
this space there's so many opportunities and it's
so unbelievable um even just in journalism because
the entire traditional world in any sense it
doesn't want to change it doesn't want to innovate
it doesn't want to grow um whereas this space
everybody wants to grow and i think it's amazing
um but just finally what are you up to and where
can people find you um just chill yourself ari
uh i'm a nice thing is i really never have
anything to show in that um no i mean i
seriously it and it it makes it pleasant
in that i'm just chatting with you and
offering my sincere views because i really
i don't have any i'm not selling anything um
uh so i'm i i'm on twitter at ari david paul um
that's how people can reach me in any content
i produce in any forum i post there um yeah
that's it and then i will probably be in uh
in miami for the bitcoin conference and i will
be in miami after that generally so you can you
know look me up we can get coffee there we
go ari i want to thank you so much um it's
just been so great it's been such a pleasure i've
learned so much particularly um all about energy
i'm still fascinated by the point you made about
um it being unconstitutional to ban bitcoin i've
actually written that down so i'm gonna go do some
research on that um but yeah i want to thank you
so much it's been great my pleasure thank you
for having me absolutely and guys thank you
so much for tuning in thank you to the sponsors
and we'll see you all next week on thursday bye